des moines est ce que tu crois au péché
originel à temps puisqu'on à la rubrique
péché est un péché qui doit être
original parce que je le fais tout le
temps et qui est que je le vends que
deux mois donne aujourd hui toujours on
me dit alors le metteur en scène ça
devient on toinon le mettait en scène la
pièce et daniel benoin et cette pièce a
été produite à la comédie de
saint-etienne et alors il faut le dire
c'est le genre s'était confessé dans le
premier budget oui ah oui cette annonce
et il fallait maintenant maintenant que
je suis tous deux viennent nettoyer tout
m'a plu de pêcher non ce n'est pas le
péché d'orgueil c'est le péché du bo
centrisme rose à peu d'un péché dire si
tu avais pas lu ou centriste uc voilà
ouais parce que tu pêches par avarice
annonça j'aimerais bien alors là à
est ce que j'aimerais bien après oui ce
que tu pêches par gourmandise
ah non pas gourmande noms sont fédérées
cuisine comme ça fera mal je me démerde
non je suis pas très gourmand non parce
que tu peux je pars en vies croisées
m'est arrivé c'est pas toi je viens tu
l'invités concurrent chrome fait pas
tout les pauvres non ça devait arriver
menacé par exemple c'était là je dis
pêche par colère trop rarement ça vaut
vraiment non je suis pas tellement
coléreuse un but qui jusqu'à présent lui
les cercles parfaits charm el cheikh
gueye ou la paresse la wii la galère sur
pattes après des monologues du new year
parker s'est pas de l'appareil
le civ est ce que ça j'apprends tout
salut mais non non je suis fait masser
comme i am et où les tire-au-flanc une
première tout tu vois ce genre si je
peux éviter mais je sais pas moi de
passer l'épongé sur l'interprète de
miettes j'éviterai tu laisses le mien
suffit à wittes ou photos à la paresse m
lui quand je pense que dans les
interviews turquie dix clés mais qui
laisse deux minutes sur la table c'est
toi qui lui allait comme il a calé et je
n'empêche pas il n'interdit pas qu'on
passe l'épongé mais bon on passe
l'épongé ce que tu pêches par luxueux
aux autres enfin le samedi est ce que tu
crois en dieu dieu directement dieu non
mais alors effectivement ces tonneaux
les progrès de la science puisse qu'ils
en arrivent à dire que après le big bang
lors la façon dont l'univers s'est créé
et organisé ne peut pas contrairement à
ce que praille et mono ya quelques
années être le fruit du hasard
voilà il ya trop de coïncidences c'est à
dire c'est la science qui ramène à
l'aide des dieux au bout du moins de 2
quel est ce d'où vient cette
organisation et au diable tu y crois
les diables n'ont alors j ai jamais cru
même à l'époque où je croyais en dieu et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
devine alors dit tu es abonné vous
mettez un pouce bleus